a little over a year ago president trump
sat down for an interview with leslie
stahl in which he complained that the
democrats and the deep state
spied on his presidential campaign
and leslie stahl was having none of it
she pushed back she dismissed the claims
she said the charge was baseless
so the biggest scandal was when they
spied on my campaign they spied on my
campaign there's no real evidence of
that of course there is it's all over
the place leslie they spied on my
campaign and they got caught can i say
something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify put it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't vote it's fine i'm totally
verified no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it over here as a matter of fact i don't
know that
no no no la la la no this is 60 minutes
this totally crazy you're a conspiracy
theorist how dare you make such a whoops
whoops here it is turns out he was
totally right
totally
100 right as of
just a few days ago
we now have firm proof that not only did
hillary clinton affiliates spy on donald
trump when he was a candidate
but they even went so far as to spy on
him when he was president
all in a desperate effort to frame him
for colluding with the russians
something democrats have been doing for
100 years according to special counsel
john durham's latest doj report
quote
the government's evidence at trial will
also establish that among the internet
data tech executive one and his
associates
uh exploited was domain name system
internet traffic pertaining to
one a particular healthcare provider two
trump tower three donald trump central
park west apartment building
and four
the executive office of the president of
the united
states trump reacted to the news in
exactly the way you would expect saying
quote this is a scandal far greater in
scope and magnitude than watergate and
those who were involved in and knew
about this spying operation should be
subject to criminal prosecution in a
stronger period of time in our country
this crime would have been punishable by
death
classic trump
pushing the window of acceptable speech
rightward getting people to accept
prosecution as the moderate position
with
execution as the further right solution
and by the way he's right on that front
too espionage can be a capital offense
and spying on the sitting president is
about as serious
as it gets so we now know
that the democrats themselves did
basically everything they accused trump
of doing
we know that trump has been proven right
on some of his wildest claims sitting
there with leslie stahl oh no this is
crazy it's a conspiracy theory some of
his wildest claims completely correct
who knows how many more wild claims he
will be vindicated on especially now
that we know the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth is about
six to 18 months we know this is one of
the most egregious abuses of power in
u.s history
and we know that not only are the
democrats not the responsible and
patriotic adults in the room that
they've made themselves out to be but
their behavior is somehow even more
depraved than their most trenchant
critics thought i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from batman for
president
who says
jimmy carter i'm the worst president in
american history joe biden hold my crack
pipe uh i mean smoking kits that's true
it's true we're all we all have to hold
that crack pipe now that is that is what
the administration is offering us not
great it's not something of great value
to hold on to
unlike say i don't know gold
when you want to invest in gold i would
strongly recommend you check out birch
gold 40 years ago ronald reagan saw a
massive inflation unlike anything the
country had ever seen before
until today
in reagan's own words inflation is as
violent as a mugger as frightening as an
armed robber and as deadly as a hitman
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration if you
have not yet called birch gold to the
only people that i would trust to help
you diversify your 401ks and iras into
gold then you are missing the boat
actually you're treading water without a
life vest
birch gold has your life vest let them
help you convert an ira or 401k into a
tax sheltered ira in gold with thousands
of satisfied customers and an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
you can trust birch gold to protect your
savings right now text knowles know w l
e s to 98 98 98
you will get a free info kit on gold
reagan knew the biggest threat to our
wealth protect yours now here's what you
do you pull out that phone you say 2 9 8
9 8 9 8 and you text the word knowles
k-w-l-e-s to get your free info kit now
not only was trump right about the
spying
he didn't go far enough
the reality was actually even more
depraved
than what donald trump
accused his opponents of engaging in
you want to talk about depravity i
it's valentine's day so i was hoping we
could talk about sort of higher
romantic
notions of love
mature
deep
rightly ordered notions of love
but we've got to talk about
joe biden's
new energy official who is in charge of
nuclear waste in america
you you want to talk about people aren't
talking about and i feel like we should
all be talking about the leather daddy
dog fetishist that joe biden just put in
charge of america's nuclear waste
the man's i don't even want to say his
name
because i don't want to embarrass him
personally except i guess i wouldn't be
embarrassing him personally you know i i
wouldn't want to reveal
someone's personal sins
needlessly that's not something i want
to do but in this case it's not a
personal sin it's a very public very
creepy scandal for someone who is not in
any way shy about this kind of behavior
who is now in a fairly powerful position
in the us government so i guess i'll say
his name his name is sam brinton
he is the new deputy assistant secretary
of spent fuel and waste disposition at
the office of nuclear energy at the does
this is a pretty serious position and
and sam brinton identifies as a and this
is in his own public biography as a
non-binary
man who is who engages in something
called puppy play
where which i i guess is sexual i guess
it's sexual but i don't
it's a sexual in a very strain
he
has men who pretend to be dogs and he
pretends to be their owner
and then for much of the this
activity they're not
it's all sexual but it's not like
explicitly sexual until
until it is it's really weird i've we've
sometimes talked about this people write
into this show a lot and say you know i
look at porn and i don't want to look at
porn but i'm really addicted to this
stuff and and one of the things that
happens
is that you you know you look at it's
just like naked ladies on the internet
and by the end you know you're looking
at um you know two chickens doing
calculus and somehow that's sexual but
you don't really know how that sexual
but it but it is it's still part so
that's that's basically what this guy is
into
and he brags about this he gives classes
on this sort of thing on all various uh
fetishes and kinks and
strange behaviors he gave an interview
to the student newspaper at the rpi
rensselaer polytechnic institute where
brenton this is according to the
newspaper quote throughout the entire
talk brenton was open about his
experiences the kinks he partakes in and
the nature of his relationships he left
us with countless anecdotes like how he
enjoys tying up his significant other
like a table and eating his dinner on
him while he watches star trek
me
i like brunettes
you know that's kind of one of and and
this guy likes to tie up his sexual
partners like they're a table and eat
sushi off of them while he watches
science fiction
in in the old days this guy would have
been a huge blackmail risk because he
has all these weird sexual behaviors
that he's indulging all the time
and people would find out about it and
then they could blackmail him
now he's not real he's not really a
blackmail risk because it's all public
so there's nothing to blackmail
but that is really
really degraded
it's really no one
no if this man were your father i don't
think that or you're your grandfather i
don't think somebody would say you know
you know my grandfather i so admire him
he fought in world war ii that's right
and my grandfather he worked at the coal
mines and it was tough work but he
earned a living for our family and he
put his sons through school and and then
here i am today his grandson they say oh
wow michael that's really interesting
yeah my grandfather liked to dress up in
leather and whip other extremely
perverted men who dressed up like
doggies and feed them a bowl of water
yeah so our you know our grandfathers
aren't we so proud of them
grandfathers right aren't they they're
people to look up to no you would be
extremely embarrassed and ashamed of
this because it's very shameful behavior
it's not in any way dignified
and
previous i'm not even saying
i'm not even saying that this guy is so
bad because he's got some disordered
sexual desires it's a fallen world lots
and lots of people have disordered
sexual desires i'm not but
in a normal healthy society the right
the thing that you would do is repress
those desires
because they are shameful
to quote nor macdonald one of the great
ethicists and moral philosophers of our
age sex is a filthy shameful thing that
is obviously only meant for procreation
okay and this is not when you when you
just spend your time
indulging in fantasies
and
childish
delusions
that's that's not a distinguished life
okay that's not something to write home
about
there was there was a poet a sort of
modern poet who said the thing about sin
even beyond how bad it is and you know
it harms people and harms yourself is
just such a waste of time
but that's what we're living in today
we're living in an age where adults
fully grown adults will spend hours and
hours and days and days and weeks and
weeks
dressing up in costumes and playing
pretend and doing all sorts of weird
creepy sex stuff that is childish
behavior for a childish society that
would appear to be past its prime you
know what's not past its prime though
the jordan harbinger show do you want a
new podcast to look forward to each week
one that is entertaining informative and
packed with actionable content of course
you do it's about time you check out the
jordan harbinger show a top shelf
podcast named best of apple in 2018
jordan dives into the minds of
fascinating people from athletes to
authors to scientists to mobsters to
spies he's had a lot of great guests
including kobe bryant without fail he
pulls out tactical bits of wisdom in
each episode all with the noble cause
making you a more informed critical
thinker to better operate in today's
world he's also got this terrific
segment feedback friday where jordan
covers advice on everything from psycho
family situations to relationships to
networking he gives great advice i
always really really enjoy his show you
can't go wrong with adding the jordan
harbinger show to your rotation it's
interesting there's never a dull show
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy i-n as in nancy
g-e-r as in really do it right now on
apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts i did not watch
a single second of the super bowl
yesterday i don't care about football i
really don't care about football ever
since they totally cave to blm and
disrespected our country it's not my
thing
i used to enjoy gambling on the super
bowl at least being in a pool was kind
of fun but now
the nfl doesn't like our country i don't
like the nfl simple as that
i did however catch clips
of the advertisements and the halftime
show afterwards
and all that that they were selling the
most prominent
ads
and the halftime show obviously all it
was selling
was nostalgia
oh do you remember when you were a kid
oh do you remember when everything was
just about indulging your own desires
and delusions and fantasies kind of like
this kid working this kid he's a fully
grown adult working at the the biden
department of energy who pretends that
he is a a doggy or he pretends that his
sexual partners are doggies and it's
really creepy and weird and none of this
should be
encouraged publicly
but it's the same old it's just
indulging in childish delusions and what
the super bowl was selling was all
nostalgia nostalgia
is history after a few drinks okay
nostalgia is
all the happy moments that we remember
or imagine and none of the tough moments
none of the things we've overcome to
become the adults that we are today the
creepiest ad of the entire super bowl
came from facebook which has now renamed
itself meta because it's trying to
expand beyond
beyond just a regular old social network
where you can like people's photos and
catch up with old friends they want to
expand into a whole universe the
metaverse where you put on your gut you
sit in your apartment alone you put on
your goggles and you enter into candy
land where you can do whatever you want
you can fly around you're not allowed to
grope people anymore that was a problem
in the beta testing but they've gotten
rid of that so if you want to do that
you got to go to the weird doggie
dungeon with the department of energy
guy but when you're in the metaverse you
can just
relive
your past as though time has never moved
on
[Music]
so here you see
there's like little stuffed animals
playing old-timey songs
and then
i moved on
the diner is closed
stuffed animal musicians go to a pawn
shop
grow up now they've got they've been
discarded
it's not fun anymore
a little long in the tooth
please we're
this had so much more boring than their
fun youth
they were all playing those old songs
from the 80s
oh but now they're in the magical
metaverse world they put the goggles
on and no one has gotten any older
everyone's the same young age they were
in the 80s
and the diner well diner doesn't exist
anymore but in this imaginary world the
diner does exist
mediquest
ii go back and be a child
here's my
public service announcement for anybody
who is tempted to to indulge this kind
of stuff
grow up grow up stop being a child and
be an adult and accept responsibility
and stop being so freaking selfish and
immature oh my gosh people
people this is so true it's so it's
clearest on the weird sex stuff like the
weird guy playing around and pretending
he's a dog at the department of energy
but it's just it's true in our whole
culture
the fact that now
not 20 year old college students say
they need a safe space with crayons and
puppies it's the same it's the same
problem the fact that now you have
employees at major companies who say
they need space to cry
they need crying rooms
they do they they say this at law school
georgetown law school the dean of the
law school said to what 25 26 30 year
old students you need you need space to
cry if your feelings are hurt
this is the the same thing you're seeing
with people refusing to get married
among millennials and especially gen z
they're still slightly young for this
but you're starting to see some of the
data no one wants to get married and
with the millennials they're now old
even though they all pretend they're
still 17 years old but they're older and
they they still won't get married i'm
not saying you have to get married
marriage isn't for everybody but they
they're not they're not consecrating
themselves to religious life they're not
they're not
moving forward they're just remaining in
a perpetual adolescence that meta ad
it was fine it was a well-produced ad
but frankly i prefer the original
version of that ad
i won't grow up i don't wanna go to
school
[Music]
[Music]
not me that's the that's the song of the
millennial generation
i'm a millennial but that's that's what
we all sing i won't grow up
uh even this phrase you know millennials
use this phrase adulting the first time
they pay taxes or whatever they say i'm
boy i'm adulting
yeah you're 40. i hope you're adulting
the people who who refuse to move out of
their parents home
not because even they have particularly
close relationships to their parents
just because they want to pay bills they
don't want to go move on
they say well i can save money yeah
because you're not paying your bills
because you're not acting like an adult
you should act
like this is my psa it's i'm not i don't
want to be overly harsh here i want to
harsh anyone's mellow but you need to
grow up because if you don't grow up
you're going to end up as a 35 year old
puppy fetishist okay you are you are
because
because if you think that it's okay
in your adulthood during a time when you
should be maturing and taking on
responsibilities and contributing to
your country and leaving your kids who
hopefully you're some some of us are
having kids i hope i hope some people in
this generation or the country's just
going to completely collapse
but hopefully you're leaving them a
better country than you had hopefully
you got to enjoy a nice little childhood
now you're going to give back
but if you are living under the delusion
that it's okay just to indulge whatever
fantasies and whatever delusions and
whatever
weird desires that you have then you're
gonna end up dancing around in weird
costumes
pretending that you're six years old
except creepier because it involves sex
stuff when you're in your 30s or 40s
don't do that it's weird it's degraded
it's
embarrassing
don't you can't go back you can't go
back to never neverland okay don't go
oh my gosh you can't go to the hundred
acre wood all right it's over
you know do you know that song back in
pooh corner can't help me if you can i
want to go back kenny loggins write this
song it's about he's graduating high
school and he says i want to go back to
my childhood but i know i can't it's not
possible so that's the way it goes well
when he rewrote the song later on in
life he said he got to go back to poo
corner he got to go back to his
childhood
by participating in his own children's
childhood so now he's in a different
role
okay it's not that you can never have
these similar joys or imagination or but
you have to do it in the role that is
appropriate to you and that is not in
leather smacking around grown men who
are barking
if you won't grow up you can't be free
that's the if you won't mature and grow
and be educated then you can't be a free
person all right and and that's what the
ruling class is banking on the liberal
establishment is consistently
undermining our freedoms
our political freedoms to make our own
choices about how we want to live and to
set our own standards for sure they're
undermining that
and they're often doing it in the name
of individual freedoms well the people
of
tennessee can't pass a law outlawing the
weird creepy leather daddy puppy stuff
because you know that would undermine
the natural right that people have to
act like weirdos no you don't have that
right but but by the way
the the ruling class is taking away your
individual freedoms too joe biden just
laughed at the very notion of individual
freedom
you were interviewed a year ago about
the super bowl and you expressed hope
that come this year that they'd be able
to fill the stands again with people
and that apparently is going to be the
case however
many of those people won't be wearing
masks despite the local law in los
angeles what is your message to people
who want desperately for this to be over
and to be able to resume the lives that
they remember
well look um
i love how people talk about personal
freedom
if you're exercising personal freedom
freedom put someone else in jeopardy
their health in jeopardy
i don't consider that being very deal
with freedom
i love how people you if you were
scripting this in some science fiction
movie you were writing star wars port 75
you would have the bad guy sound like
this and have that voice and say these
things
you're you're a personal freedom
oh and i hear about your personal
freedom they don't like it they don't
like it the democrats never liked it i
know that some people are going to
respond and say but but i thought the
liberals were all for personal freedom i
thought the democrats were all the party
of personal freedom no they never were
they never were
that was always an instrument to control
people
oh yeah you've got the freedom to search
for whatever you want on the internet
but we're going to be spying on you and
we're going to see all that data and
we're going to use it to try to
undermine you oh yeah you're free to do
whatever creepy stuff you want to do on
your own oh yeah you're free to do
you're free to indulge all of your
basest appetites and then become slaves
to those appetites yeah you're free to
smoke crack here we're even going to
send you a crack pipe but then that'll
make you a free person right no it'll
make you completely
incapable of self-government which is
exactly what they want
you know the opening weekend of our
first original production shut-in was a
huge success not only did our premiere
reach over half a million views
but the reviews are in and shut-in has a
critic score this is genuinely
astounding to me let's get a critic
score of 100
i figure i look i think the movie is
terrific but i figured that the lib
critics would get in there and really be
able to bring that down they haven't
critics store is extremely high perfect
score the audience score is 98
on rotten tomatoes imdb is giving it
eight out of ten i think the libs
probably got in there a little bit uh
making a good film is not easy but we
did it
that's why if you missed it i am telling
you you gotta head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe get a membership
today the film is now exclusively
streaming for daily wire members if you
are not one you're missing out we also
released the new trailer for hyperions
the new anti-superhero movie starring
carrie elwes i don't know how to
pronounce his name exactly but he's the
guy from princess bride it's pretty cool
it comes out in a few weeks and also the
trailer for terror on the prairie which
is our new western starring the amazing
uncancelable gina carano coming this
summer this great entertainment is all
thanks to our daily wire members so head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe so
you can watch shut in hyperions and
gina's new movie coming out this summer
we'll be right back with a lot more
democrats are beginning to lift the mask
mandates
not because the public health officials
have observed that the masks are mostly
useless they've been doing that since
the beginning fauci admitted they don't
do very much sometimes they hurt during
an epidemic but democrats still pushed
for it
the
cnn medical expert lyanna wu said weeks
ago that the cloth masks are nothing
more than facial decorations still the
democrats kept up on the face masks but
now they're getting their poll numbers
and the poll numbers on these mass
mandates are really really bad and the
democrats are looking like they're going
to get clobbered in november so all of a
sudden democrat governors are saying no
we're not the party of mass mandates no
we no we hate mass mandates we're
actually we're going to get rid of the
mass mandates because of how successful
our policies have been and the only
problem with this pivot with this
strategy is that joe biden is
he's lost a few steps he's not really
with it he's not keeping up with the new
talking points and so joe biden goes on
lester holt's show on nbc and he's still
pushing the old talking voice he's
saying hold up hold up hold up
i still like the mask mandates
are you afraid though that some states
and cities are moving too quickly to
loosen indoor mask mandates well you
know it's uh
i've
i committed that i would follow the
science the science as put forward by
the cdc
and and and the federal people and uh i
think it's probably premature but it's
you know it's a tough call
this is probably premature i followed
followed the science now he doesn't
follow the science the science is not to
be followed but he's not he's clearly
not following it anyway because now all
of those hacks in the public health
bureaucracy are saying okay yeah you can
move on you can move on because they're
basically indistinguishable from the
democrat politicians and from the
liberal media they're all working in
concert together joe biden just hasn't
caught up to the latest political
talking points
which is a beautiful thing because he's
not going to let the democrats
get away with their
their attempted deception
they're trying to pretend that they are
not now and really never were the party
that wanted mask mandates
they grudgingly accepted them but they
never wanted them and biden is saying no
we do we do don't get rid of the mask
mandates that's a republican thing the
republic he's really giving you a choice
he's saying the republicans don't want
the mass mandates the democrats do good
i hope that's on the ballot in november
we're going to take every single seat
it's not this is not the only place
where democrats are undermining their
own message
for
two three years now
what has been
one of the most
prominent animating principles of the
democratic party
including especially the blm riots
and all the criminal justice reform of
recent years it's been abolish the
police defund the police abolish prisons
remember that we've heard this
ad nauseam for years now
and then the democrats got their poll
numbers back and it turns out abolish
the police is not all that popular
during a crime wave in a midterm
election year and so nancy pelosi
goes on abc news she tries to use all of
her jedi mind tricks she says no no
we don't we don't want to defund the
police these are not the droids that
you're looking for and
because the democrats control the media
she thinks it's going to be very
effective
the other thing that's weighing on
people right now is rising crime uh and
there appear to be some divisions among
democrats about how to handle it your
colleague karen bass running for mayor
of los angeles is trying to increase the
police force in l.a corey bush
congresswoman from missouri is saying
it's time to defund the police he's
sticking by that you're the speaker how
do you think democrats should address
rising crime well with all the respect
in the world for court push that is not
the position of the democratic party
community safety
to protect and defend in every way is
our oath of office
and i
have sympathy
we're all concerned about mistreatment
of people and that's why
karen bass had the justice and policing
act and we would hope to get some of
that done whether it's no knock or joke
holt or some of those issues even if we
can't get it all done but the but make
no mistake
community safety is our responsibility
nice try nancy but i don't think you're
really persuading me notice she gets
tripped up on her words because look
we're all we're all really sympathetic
to defund the pool i mean no we're all
we're not gosh we are really sympathetic
and we've all been pushing this thing
for a long time but uh
no but and then the way that george
stephanopoulos frames it is he says look
you got cory bush on one hand who is
still pushing to abolish the police
defund the police but then you've got
karen bass on the other hand karen bass
who's a democrat congressman she's a
communist she's like an actual communist
who is a member for a long time of
actual communist organizations
and karen bass is now running for mayor
of l.a karen bass wants to increase
police funding
uh does she i don't i don't buy that for
one second and nancy pelosi apparently
doesn't either because she points out
that karen bass has previously supported
soft on crime bills to make it harder to
prosecute criminals to make it harder to
arrest criminals so that the two polls
here the pro crime and and the weak on
crime democrats they're both extremely
weak on crime they both wanted to defund
the police they both wanted to make it
harder to arrest people
and nancy pelosi went along with this
for a long time and and so did other
very prominent democrats aoc what did
she say she said
defund the police means defund the
police
abolish the police means abolish the
police doesn't mean move a little
funding around here or there it means
get rid of that funding
rashida talib
the george harrison of the squad
you've got aoc is paul mccartney she's
the most mainstream ilhan omar is a
little more radical she's john lennon
ayanna presley everyone forgets about
she's ringo so you got rashida who is
george harrison and rashida talib comes
out in an interview with axios just a
few months ago and said yes i want to
abolish all prisons
and the the reporter couldn't he said
what you want you want to abolish all
federal prisons you want to let all
murderers rapists serial killers out and
she said well
uh basically
yes
yes i do
and they know that this is destroying
their poll numbers and so they're trying
to run away from it and nancy pelosi is
saying don't believe you're lying out
she says it's not the position of the
democrat party well i don't know darling
when it's the position of a huge number
of very prominent congressmen when it's
the position of major democrat mayors
and governors all around the country
then i think it is the position of the
party and you're going to try to lie
through your teeth
and just hope that people aren't paying
attention in an election year but i
think the people probably know better
they're they're flipping on all their
policies now because of how unpopular
they are beto o'rourke he's my favorite
one he's running for office for i think
the 75th time in 18 months he's remember
he
he ran for
president
he ran for senate lost ran for president
lost now he's running for governor of
texas he's probably going to lose beta
or work what did he say a few years ago
it's very clear they said are you going
to try to take away people's ar-15s and
he said
hell hell yes i'm gonna take your guns
hell yes we're gonna take your ar-15
your ak-47 we're not gonna allow it to
be used against our fellow americans
anymore
i'm not interested in taking anything
from anyone what i want to make sure
that we do is defend the second
amendment i want to make sure that we
protect our fellow texans far better
than we're doing right now and that we
listen to law enforcement
hmm is that the same
is that the same guy he went so 2019 you
say hell yes i'm taking your guns then
2022 he says we're not taking guns from
anybody i don't want to i want to defend
the second amendment i'm a pro second
amendment guy because now i'm running
for governor of texas not the democrat
nomination for president i'm pro okay so
listen maybe he changed his mind people
can grow people can change people can
mature they don't usually do that these
days but maybe they can
except
that just just one year ago
back in not even one year even less than
one year ago
in just a few months ago beto o'rourke
was
saying that he stood by his call to take
away people's guns
look we we are a state that has a long
proud tradition of responsible gun
ownership and most of us here in texas
do want do not want to see our friends
our family members our neighbors shot up
with these weapons of war so yes i still
hold this view
yes yes i still hold this view hell yes
we're going to take away your ar-15s and
he's trying to have it both ways so he
he started the shift
it back in november so he said
i love the second amendment
i just hate
the most popular gun in america
so yeah we're going to defend your
abstract second amendment right in
principle but in practice we're going to
take away the most popular basic gun in
america
so the issue here is not that he changed
his views i'm happy when politicians
flip-flop from the wrong side of an
issue to the right side of an issue i'm
basically pretty happy about that the
issue here is that beto is obviously
insincere and if he somehow became
governor of texas he would obviously
push for strong
gun grabbing legislation
and i think the people see through that
especially with him i mean he's just
such a joke
he that guy you know he can go back to
skateboarding around the whataburger he
does not he he looks like a child he
look he gets back to what we were
talking about at the top of the show
gets back to people wanting to go back
to their nightclub in the 1980s people
wanting to go back to childhood and play
around and pretend they're puppies
except in a much much creepier way
i hope than they did when they were kids
it goes back to that nostalgia
i won't grow up i won't grow up that p
beto o'rourke is the never never land
candidate
running for running for governor of
never never land texas ain't never never
land at least not now at least i hope
people want politicians who will toughen
up on criminals
and not toughen up on law-abiding
citizens what the democrats have been
offering
especially on this gun issue is we're
going to go really hard after
law-abiding gun owners and we're going
to let criminals who are using illegal
guns at a prison and then we're going to
abolish prisons all together that seems
backwards doesn't it which is why
republicans have just introduced
i would say my favorite
law ever
well that's not true my favorite bill
that has been introduced in congress
recently
is the michael knowles public health
protection pledge which was just
introduced as a house resolution by
representative paul gosar it's a pledge
to
investigate subpoena investigate and
then defund dr fauci it's a great pledge
your congressman your senators can sign
on right now as co-sponsors tell them to
write them tag them say sign on to the
michael knowles public health protection
pledge sign on to paul gosar's pledge
that he's put into congress and make
sure that we get rid of fouchy that's a
little bit of a sidebar but other than
the michael knowles public health
protection pledge my my favorite bill
that has been introduced into congress
possibly ever
is a bill to ban the government
from paying for crack pipes for drug
addicts the bill
is called the halting the use see if you
can follow this one
halting the use of narcotics through
effective recovery act of 2022
also known as the hunter act
to ban crack pipes
really really great stuff politicians
love a good
acronym this one
as good as they get absolutely hilarious
but also a good law
also a good law
the
democrat theory of justice that is very
prominent today not not just among the
democrat party proper but among the
whole american left which now controls
all the institutions
is that the way to have a good society
is
to let people do whatever they want
to let
that's not true you're not you're not
really allowed to start businesses
you're not really allowed to go to
church you're not allowed to walk around
without a mask
you're not allowed to avoid getting 17
jabs of an experimental drug
so it's not that you're allowed to do
absolutely whatever you want i guess the
theory on the left and among democrats
is that you have some kind of right to
engage in any destructive behaviors that
you want
whether they're destructive on drugs
whether they're distracted destructive
on weird sex stuff whether they're
destructive
on
on even in your local community looting
going and stealing nike shoes
not prosecuting a lot of these crimes
they're they're all for that
the democrats think that's how you're
going to have a flourishing society
the never never land party
imagine if kids were allowed to do that
kids are not allowed to do that kids are
told don't do the bad thing naughty
naughty do the good thing good job good
job little boy and then you grow up and
then hopefully you can govern yourself
but something about this generation or a
lot of recent generations they never
learned that they never agreed to grow
up
and if we want to hold on to whatever
tenuous little threat of a country that
we have left we're gonna need to grow up
and we're gonna need to say no don't
smoke crack
no
we're not we can't mail out people crack
pipes we've got to say no naughty
naughty crackhead don't smoke that crack
don't no don't dress up like a puppy and
prance around and then take over
america's nuclear waste no you got to
grow up
you got i hate to be the bad guy i don't
want to sound like i don't want to sound
like mean old daddy here but not daddy
like in the sense of what the puppy guy
is would say daddy i'm talking about
like actually father knows best there is
such a thing as reason and moral
conscience and justice and virtue and
you got to pursue that if you want to
have a real
society
speaking of republican legislators
republican legislators are weighing in
now
on an important international issue i'm
not talking about ukraine which is an
extremely overhyped issue
i'm not talking about other places where
the state department wants to go
intervene around the world i'm talking
about the one international issue that
the liberal establishment the ruling
class doesn't want to talk about at all
i'm talking about that international
issue going on up in america's hat i'm
talking about the most important worker
protest of not just our lifetimes
probably the most important worker
protest of the last hundred years
i'm talking about the canadian truckers
senator rand paul
very libertarian
defender of individual liberty
unsurprisingly
now it's funny because rand paul being
extremely libertarian he doesn't like to
get involved in foreign countries and he
always votes against sanctions he always
votes against foreign intervention but
in this case he is speaking out and he's
saying those canadian truckers
are are doing great work and they're
standing up for liberty
i'm all for it civil disobedience civil
disobedience is a time-honored tradition
in our country
from slavery to civil rights to you name
it peaceful protest
clog things up maple make people think
about the mandates
so he's saying this is great stuff this
is civil disobedience
and some people
on the left and in the center
are accusing rand paul and other
conservatives who really like the the
canadian trucker protest
they're saying hong kong conk and
they're they're sending their support
they're accusing us of hypocrisy
because they're saying hold on a second
hold on a second you hypocrites
back a year or two ago during the blm
riots you were against those you were
against that civil disobedience
pretty uncivil disobedience by the way
when you're throwing molotov cocktails
at federal buildings and eluding nike
sneakers but regard let's even grant the
premise you were against
blm taking to the streets but you're for
the canadian truckers there's a guy he
he writes for a libertarian magazine not
i don't even want to use that term
libertarian because
libertarianism has a sort of strain of a
serious tradition and a lot of the
people today who call themselves
libertarians are just not that they call
them libertarians sometimes because
they're really incoherent and really
kind of squishy so i do want to make
that distinction but anyway he's a nice
guy i don't want to go after him
personally but but he made a really dumb
point
which is he tweeted out quote from
conservatives cheering for an
economically crippling worker-led
blockade to liberals essentially
plagiarizing tom cotton's send in the
troops op-ed the trucker protests are
turning basically everyone into
hypocrites and it is hilarious
the conservatives say it's beautiful to
see people fighting injustice and
standing up against mistreatment and if
they disrupt the economy and occupy
public roads so be it the liberals are
saying arrest them jail the dissenters
blow up the trucks could not have
scripted this better you can retort now
do blm at both groups and it works
amazing and then he goes on to conclude
i think all the mandates should end and
the truckers should disperse in the
previous scenario i thought we should
end no knock raids and also people
should stop rioting
see i'm a good one i'm one of the good
ones
i'm
listen i'm much smarter than all of the
conservatives talking about the vaccine
mandates and i'm much smarter than all
of the liberals talking about abolish
the police
i'm they're you're just hypocrites
because if you
if you support blm then you should
support the truckers and vice versa if
you support the truckers then you should
support the violent mobs roving through
the streets right
wrong
no
do you know what i find hilarious i
don't find this hilarious i don't think
it's hypocritical at all what i find
hilarious is that
some people are only now figuring out
that politics
is not merely about procedural norms but
also about substantive ends
i'll bring that down to earth what i
mean is
yes
blm
and the canadian truckers
both protested that's true they were
both protesting
that's the procedural similarity
but they were protesting for very very
different things
blm was protesting to abolish the police
blm was protesting to let criminals run
roughshod over our society blm was
protesting to make it harder to arrest
criminals
the canadian truckers are protesting
because they don't want to be forced to
take an experimental drug with noted
recorded side effects to maybe sort of
but probably not protect against a virus
that doesn't pose a grave threat to most
people
those are different things
and it met this is i sometimes hear this
whenever you talk about religion and
politics which you inevitably have to do
because all politics ultimately comes
back to religion whether you want to
admit it or not all politics comes back
to these moral questions sometimes
they'll say wait a second michael hold
on if you
if you apply religious and moral
thinking
to
to politics if you apply your christian
world view to politics well you're no
different than isis because isis also
applies their religious world view to
politics
so yeah that's yes that's true now let's
go a step further it's right you're
right all people have some kind of
religion even if you think you don't
have a religion you do have a religion
you talk about things like human rights
and free will and the relationship of
man to this you always have some kind of
religious view yes so people talk about
religion
but the religions are different
they they're different they have
different views of the world and they
have different implications for politics
and society
yeah you're right and christianity and
islam are different and christianity and
islam and leftism are very very
different and it matters the substance
matters too
this is so hilarious that some people
would support the truckers but not blm
no it's just to be expected because
those are different groups with
different aims with different views of
society that's why it's perfectly
ordinary and normal to support one and
not
the others it's very don't it's very
shallow view of politics my friends
and it's not you are seeing a kind of
shifting of some political alliances
right now for instance
you're seeing the liberal establishment
really push for war
in ukraine but it's not just
conservatives pushing for war and you
pushing against the war in ukraine it's
it's some liberal media figures too jake
tapper was just pushing back on the
national security adviser jake sullivan
you've been warning about the russians
using a false flag operation to justify
invading ukraine that's a strong claim
to make without presenting a shred of
evidence is there anything more you can
tell the public a public that might be
justifiably rather skeptical of claims
about intelligence
well let me make three points on this
first we're not putting forward this
intelligence to start a war which has
happened in the past jake we are putting
forward this intelligence to stop a war
and i think that fundamentally gives it
at the outset a different level of
credibility okay we've we've seen them
do this before okay and but jake
tapper's just sitting here he's saying
what evidence do you have you're not
presenting any evidence
so who knows maybe putin invades ukraine
maybe he doesn't
all but that's sort of beside the point
the issue is that the deep state has
lost all credibility that's why people
don't believe the state department
briefings that's why people don't
believe when the pentagon says we got to
go in there we got to send in the troops
is because they've lied they've bungled
a whole lot of foreign interventions and
they've lied and now it's just a group
of puppy fetishists and domestic spies
who are undermining the sitting
president that's not our fault you guys
squandered your credibility that's why
the people are making
what might be a last stand at
self-government that's that's what all
of this political pushback is about
whether about whether it's the canadian
truckers or whether it's what you're
seeing going on
ahead of the 2022 elections what country
are we going to be are we going to
regress to perpetual childhood i won't
grow up i won't grow up or are we going
to decide to mature grow up and take
back control of our country i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knoll show i'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show